так видно коли його вижно україна це ан
лам розумний пам'ятник для туристів що в
пошиття рухають україну чий правиця так
на проходячи дочку і перевіряли домінік
біргіта а йоганна з мюнхена
он і приїхала у кривого інша марка
поспішаємо куль іду до вирощували картинкою то
багата на нову інформацію про Україну ось
історія культура все справлю криви так
тут чи варто так акція супер-друзі
хоче пізнати це я був ще з майданом
незалежності ж тут повернувся 2 астані
української революції розрахунок the shoes
коли отрути видних ним тихо трохи менше
історичного екскурсу
що було тут 100-200 року в тому що
символ зуя vst комплекс пам'ятників
вид вигодою до видних не дав рахунку за
зірка
шукаю за про пір шукають ця скульптура magda
знав ася, але ж за допомогу wife are so
quickly тут навпаки до його важливо
україна радість тур з такого я вилицю
адже виду ти софійський собор у козу його
адреса біля алли з хенну маршруту німа
друзі в машині в дати сяду стражнику
квесту
йдуть нам маня і від раб там а план замість
англійську на щастя знайшли місяці rust
ушивання собору встановлено овочі ворожість
виду видно до домініка
гіпсування заради соніка ти великий бували в
до виду que розмістив і можу булат
супер ним типу коли знає ч процесора
Софійський собор
алейхім зчистити та відкрито кримінальну
башта
наріжте у васька і вперед друзям і як
на долонях і он і прогризла розуміти так
стара
один новаторський на місця олег cool або
відкрити йому за це театр і яскравих і дві
дати марку ти їв гранітного стуку
інформації на кому автобусі та до транспорту
нас отримую я буду їх їду додому за їх
тисне на канади інформації
а лише такий у нього важлива україна багата
кури знову niñosi вид чує собі обидві
здані лише диво українських традицій
вишиванка з народно сорочка і річки в
баварії
ви тягаєте на терек носять а про силу дати
чудовиська зачистка частини смаку
заразна встала модну та ще й фотографії
українських страх куди видно
у таких почни що німці і без мату і
чи знаєш ти марно вати
українську кухню дуже смачно я гостро ви
на дніпрі
монумент битки в шинах а ти баба near
sea ​​pro позиції до видно до он це йшли
дві дме вона причому побачити шия кріс
вудінг